oh my friends today is your lucky day
because I just got to speak with Dustin
Tavella who is the most amazing magician
I have ever seen and has a very
inspiring story as well but it was it
was a shocking a shocking segment that
I'm still shook from and it was on the
member block okay so that's only for our
members occasionally though I'll give
you Hoy polloi just a little
few crumbs and I really I really wanted
to show people this one but you got to
become a member if you want segments
like this every single day go to
dailywire.com
so you never miss our member of blocks
okay let's bring in our friend here
Dustin develop who is a magician who
performed the most impressive trick
of the year or maybe of the last 10
years it's not that he pulled a rabbit
out of a hat it's not that he sought a
lady in hat
Dustin
managed to win a network television game
show as a straight white Christian man I
don't know I didn't think that was
possible in our day and age apparently
it is Dustin thank you for coming on the
show
what's up man thank you for having me so
this is this is an amazing story because
you you performed on and one one of the
biggest shows in the world that's
America's Got Talent and and you did it
because your craft your magic tricks are
extremely impressive but
not just a part of your character but
actually a part of your act is the fact
that you are
a pretty traditional Christian guy with
a stable family who adopts kids who just
who
exalts virtue and discourages vice I
didn't think that was possible I'm still
in shock of the fact of winning not just
because of all those things but just I
want America's Got Talent which is still
crazy to me but um yeah man it was it
was an incredible experience and I think
for us I always say that I don't feel
like it was me who won AGT I feel like
this was a win for for for Christians
for family for
um just the idea of what it looks like
to actually serve Humanity because for
us the whole the whole reason that I
even jumped in and started doing magic
again in the first place was because I
love the idea of being able to tell
stories and for us one of the biggest
things is being able to inspire people
to go out and actually be magic in the
world and so um yeah one of the most
amazing things was knowing that America
saw that they clung to the store and
they voted for it which just means
there's more of us you know rooting
um for for these kinds of values than we
thought because your act really is about
stories that is what distinguishes it
from a lot of other magic acts you're
very very good at doing the tricks I'm
waiting for you to you know I don't know
pull the rabbit out of a hat or
something from the other side I don't
know I don't know if One Can Do Magic
over Skype but but you know the the ACT
is not just these tricks you integrate
this this whole story and it's a very
personal story and it's extremely
inspiring about about your family about
your kids
yeah thanks man yeah so my my wife and I
actually did Ministry for a long time
full time actually my wife and me and my
sister started a homeless Ministry in
Los Angeles and um prior to that I was
actually pursuing a music career and I
think when we started doing the homeless
Ministry it was wild how how different I
felt like my life became simply because
when I was doing the music stuff when I
was you know focused on the
entertainment culture my whole life was
revolved around myself and everything
that I did it was all about promoting
the good things that we do and just
showing people because that's what gets
you likes and followers and when we were
doing the homeless stuff it was like
none of this stuff was caught on camera
none of this stuff was on a large scale
we were we were sitting with people who
desperately needed to know that they
were valued right it wasn't just like
let's hand the money but spent let's
raise five thousand dollars make a bunch
of tacos and then leave it was like
let's get to know these guys spend time
with them and um and the transformation
that we saw it was like it wasn't like
we were going into spaces like we saw 3
000 people get off the streets but it
was like we saw a man transformed who's
been homeless for 30 years we just heard
for the first time that he was loved and
valued and I think for us that really
hit home because uh you know we live in
such a culture where everyone's so quick
to want to post their opinions and say a
bunch of stuff
um I have a lot of friends in the
industry on both sides of these
arguments who a lot of times are just
posting things because they feel the
pressure to do it from culture just to
post about it I have a friend he's a
comedian
um recently he had a big talk with his
manager because the manager was like you
have to be posting about Ukraine right
you you can't not post about this you're
going to lose fat you know of course
you're a comedian you have to weigh in
on geopolitics and a Thousand-Year
military conflict yeah and so and so you
see this culture of people where we we
pretend to care about stuff because it's
what will get us likes is what will get
us followers and um a ton of people who
will speak on these issues and I'm like
when was the last time like if you're so
passionate about you know the lgbtq
community and the trans Community when
was the last time you actually just sat
and had lunch with one of these people
born heard their story and like we're so
we're so quick to to have an opinion and
so anyways I could go on and on and I
know we only have a short time but for
us we just became very big on like we
just want to inspire people to be magic
in the world whether people see it or
not we want to go out and we want to we
want to do the hard thing and and on our
AGT Journey you know we started AGT with
one kid
um we had adopted Xander he was two
months old and my first round I told his
story and got to share about the
adoption and stuff and part way through
AGT we got a phone call asking if we
would want to take in his biological
brother
um whose situation was a little bit more
complicated and this was the most crazy
season of life because you know my whole
world is wrapped up in trying to perform
on this stage
um and but we weren't going to say no
you know this kid he needed a home and
we we've been praying for a long time to
see these brothers grow up together and
so that was the greatest Miracle of all
that man it was most magical thing that
happened when he got to see these
brothers United and got to tell their
story
um on a platform in front of America and
millions of people and man it's just
it's been more humbling than anything
just to know that we've been a part of
kind of inspiring other people to go out
and to do the hard thing that's amazing
because I love this distinction you're
making here between
helping the poor or helping the needy in
the abstract versus doing it in in a
really tangible way because there are a
lot of people who love Humanity
in general but they don't seem to like
humans very much I'm I even I always go
back to you know the story Bartleby the
scrivener by by Herman Melville I don't
know if you read it in school a lot of
people read it it's a short story people
read in school and there are so many
lessons to take from the story but one
of the more offbeat ones is that there's
this guy Bartleby it just doesn't want
to work and he's sleeping in his office
and he's clearly pretty kooky and he
ends up in a loony bin you know and the
guy is just and what do you do with
someone who the line that he keeps going
back to whenever he's told hey do some
work hey go home hey get an apartment
hey do this do that he just says I would
prefer not to I would prefer not to and
he's so intransigent and what do you do
with people like that and I think will
you just be with them you know you just
have to kind of be with them and there's
no you can't write on a napkin five
bullet points here's how we're gonna
solve poverty we're gonna cure hunger or
whatever you know you're not gonna do
that but you might be able to change one
man's life
yeah and I think and I think that was
the big thing we noticed too because
when we were doing all the homeless
stuff people would ask you know are you
are you for free housing or not for free
housing and I'm like well who's the
person we're talking about because
there's there's families who are like in
desperate need of some kind of service
right and then there's people who have
just they're stuck in the system because
they just keep they have no motivation
to work for something right and you
can't know that unless you get to know a
person and even thinking of like and
this is both sides and I think this is
where for us man we're just passionate
about trying to help Humanity get back
to the place of like we're just all here
to to love God to know that we're loved
and then to do what Jesus did which was
like who who cares what the person's
social status is like people are worth
giving our time to and you know during
the pandemic we saw it everyone's like
oh my gosh my neighbor got covered
arguing about they should have worn a
mask they didn't have their masks
whatever and I'm like well when did you
just maybe jump in your kitchen and make
them some meals because they can't go
outside now so like should we just do
something about about it rather than
throwing our opinions at everybody about
what we believe they should have done
differently right and I think that
that's how how we've been trying to live
man and I love that we've gotten to use
um the magic to do that kind of thing
because
um you know there's a lot of people who
in our lives that we definitely do not
have the same belief systems but
um I think because of this this posture
we've gotten to have some incredible
conversations where their ears were not
closed to the things that we believe and
the things that we stand for simply
because they know that we care and
they've seen it and that's the thing we
try and encourage other people to do is
to be magic in the world man so Dustin
you were you were motivated by you know
the love of Christ and your deeply held
religious beliefs to then uh go and
engage in the dark arts of the of the
prince of lies of this world and
practice magic is that I hold on how do
you how do you square that Circle so
this is so this is this is great man
because I always say I do magic tricks
right emphasis on the word tricks I
don't I just so I'm in my parents house
right now we just flew in for Christmas
um last night late last night and um my
mom had a box of all my old stuff in the
attic and so it was just really cool
because I'm not I haven't been home in
over a year normally you know I'm
traveling home as much as I can to see
friends and family
um thankfully people have come to visit
us in in Vegas this last year this is my
first time home um since I've won
America's Got Talent and so
um you know to just sit there with my
mom going through all my own old magic
tricks just kind of remembering where I
started and where I came from and I was
like man I actually should do some of
this stuff for the show today but um but
it is a true Point what you're saying is
that sometimes you know
it is it is a strange thing and I think
for me sometimes because I have such an
understanding of how magic tricks work
actually one of the things that I found
I was excited this was one of the
awesome tricks my my floating Rose
how did how did how did no one notice
this was it now it's falling how did no
one notice this giant metal thing
hanging off of my
oh
but like but there's the thing when I'm
young this is what my magic tricks look
like right
it totally worked on me I guess I'm
fairly rudimentary on my magic you know
well I mean it might be it might be
through Skype you can't see the Diamond
metal thing poking on my thumb but um
but it's funny because to me this is
what magic tricks are right and then
it's just like as I got better now it
becomes more of a question of
spirituality but to me this is like this
is every magic trick man this is what
magic is
um which actually can I can I do
something fun for you right now please
yeah
all right cool so one of the other
things that I found was this awesome uh
box it's a dragon on it of course
because why wouldn't it
um
so essentially this is this is like a
box that I would kind of just like keep
random stuff in when I was I was young
and I would also use it for magic tricks
um I'm gonna I'm gonna get to that in
just a minute okay uh let's try
something fun I'm gonna write something
down actually this is this is the point
in my show where I would ask anybody if
they have a dollar bill I obviously
can't get a dollar bill from you right
now so yeah and unfortunately Dustin
because I work for Ben Shapiro I I don't
have a dollar bill all right perfect
well I took I took one from my dad and
this was the only Bill in his wallet by
the way so
um here we go I'm gonna write something
on here
to start
um a bit of a prediction if you will
also anytime a magician does something
with a bill it's always good to note the
serial number I don't know if you can
see this try and hold it so you can see
it
um
e24414537c just make note of that for
now um that'll be important later but
I'm gonna write I'm gonna write a little
something on there if you wanted to
write it down you can just put 537c
let's just do the last okay
let's see okay yeah perfect and um I'm
gonna actually write below something on
this bill especially for you
based on a decision I think you're about
to make okay okay here we go I want you
to give me a number between one and 100
actually do this think of a number
between one and a hundred and then
change your mind because I don't even
want you to be thinking of the number
you thought you'd be thinking of right
that's psychology okay okay
so so you got a new number I've got the
new number in my mind
between one and a hundred yes
cool what's the number you landed on
27.
27 for sure yeah okay so um we're gonna
do this uh going to my notes one of my
notes right here my notes and again if
you were here I'd have you be doing this
I have a list here of um celebrities
okay I have a hundred different
celebrities I don't know if you can see
these um what was the first number you
were thinking of
first number is 18.
18. so I'm going to stand up so I can
also see my phone as it is if you would
have picked 18 you would have got
um Jennifer Lopez I don't know if you
can see okay yeah Jennifer Lopez and you
said you and you landed on 27 yeah
who is Brad Pitt can you see Brad Pitt
right okay yep okay
so 100 different people you picked Brad
Pitt yeah could have slept at anybody
yeah yeah could have questioned anyone
um
I wrote something on this bill
and I want to show you what I wrote but
actually I want to show you in kind of a
fun way
[Applause]
um
I'm gonna take what I wrote okay
and put it into uh this box that I was
talking about yeah okay yeah my stuff
check this out bro this is where his
magic gets crazy all right
half of my bill
with my prediction written on it yeah
is it the fun part oh where's the bill
bro
I don't know where the bill went can you
do me a favor so this this thing's
actually like a portal
what if I just sent my prediction
because I wanted you to believe me
can you can you do me a favor can you
like can you can you reach in your
pocket
yeah yeah reaching your inside pocket no
okay
oh
okay
are you
oh man it says Brad Pitt right oh man
we got to make sure we check those
serial numbers look at the serial number
make sure that is the same bill
I am
entirely speechless
that was all you bro
that was our connection that's how we
start the connection but can we do one
more actually
no yeah yes we can yeah
um I want to do a card trick do you have
cards there by any chance
uh well yes okay the producers have left
my cards yeah I got I've got cards
we're gonna do something fun and my
mom's gonna kill me because I'm gonna
destroy her Christmas decorations for
just a second okay
um
I'm gonna write another thing down we're
gonna have fun this one's gonna be this
one's gonna be great it's gonna be all
on you now that we have this connection
bro I just oh wait I forgot the part
about it this goes both ways dude so I
just sent you something
um you can send you can send me
something too check this out
again totally great to know that this
box is empty yeah um
you feel anything
no like in your pants
what am I supposed to feel Dustin this
was a trick when I was 12 years old bro
um
so
check your pants dude I'm just kidding
no stupid that was weird well I would
have gone with it I literally I was
there I was like did he did this man
just strip me on my own show that was
that was 12 year old me doing a magic
trick I almost forgot the best part okay
go okay let's do this I want you I want
you to think of a of a playing card
okay and um you got one in your mind I
do yes drop in the chalk we're free and
clear
um what playing card are you thinking of
seven of Clubs
the seven of clubs yeah are you sure or
do you want to change your mind I'm a
hundred percent sure
okay I want you to remember this moment
that you do have the chance to change
your mind because everyone always says
what if I want you don't have to and
maybe I'm using Jedi Mind Tricks yeah
you can do whatever you want no I'm
sticking with the seven of clubs thank
you for the seven of clubs okay
um I'm gonna show you what I wrote
okay I wrote down 47. okay can you open
up that deck that you have right there
uh-huh
pull those cards out okay and um you
went 47 so we can count backwards if
that makes it easier because that's a
lot of cards but I want you to look at
the 47th card you could have named any
card you want all right look I'll drag
it out so starting from the top starting
up here yep yep yep and make sure all
different too says you have one yeah
good two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen Seventeen eighteen
nineteen twenty Twenty One 22 23 24 25
26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38
39 40 41 42
43 44 44 45
46. hold on what car did you say
I said the seven of Clubs
can you look at the 47th card do not do
not tell me
Dustin
um
before you just reach through the
computer and like steal my soul and you
know pull the I have to let you go that
that is
um
not only is your story extremely uh
inspiring but
um I'm now terrified of you I
mean awe of you and I'm I'm terrified
and you can levitate a rose Dustin
Tavella where can people find you
um right now man actually I'm excited I
was at Luxor for this past year uh
headline in at the ADT live show but um
been working on my new show now brand
new it's all my own so that'll be
launching in 2023 which I'm super
excited about about all the details I
can give at the moment but um yeah I'm
really really excited man 2023 is gonna
be a really fun year of getting to just
tell more stories and do more magic and
hopefully make some more people smile
Dustin keep up the great work and thank
you for coming on the show Dustin
Tavella I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael Knowles show we'll see you next
time
[Music]
if you want to see more live interviews
and reactions weeks before anybody else
go to dailywire.com
member block to get that and so much
more on daily wire plus see you there